welcome to this video on your pucks 17
let's see the Philippines I played the
sky before I'd only ones i would have
thought it would have to be more often
but ok one time one win so at least
percentage Morissette's a good score
main line oops a 4 that's rare but not
that bad interesting this we should g4
is a good reply right now sort of has to
place your three after which i'm not
sure castles all night f 5m it's a long
long time since I looked at this okay
there's always took him sometimes black
plays before in those lines but I never
really can figure out when I do I may be
here go on let's let's do it and see
what's going what's happening after it
yeah still I can go deform county 45 may
be coming right now sure that this was
such a great idea that HC Bishop b6 idea
now that that that looks very pacified
don't think that this is so great making
its own bishop and look over yet but on
the other hand what am i doing can I go
for a five maybe trying to prepare a
five maybe Bishop g5 95 getting those
bad pieces traded my chances of training
the bed bishop yeah I'm better on g5
then his bishop on c2 he getting traded
and I might get 94 so I g5 is certainly
not bad it would be surprising if it was
bad
okay so he lets me take them and get
Bishop g5 I maybe ha maybe I should have
taken d 5 while I had the chance I
definitely nakia it's so good it's so
good but this was something that I
should have done
okay let's get rid of this night if he
takes with the sea porn I think I'm fine
with this and they get in rook c8 c3
moving the Queen looks strange
yeah I'm controlling see one so that I
will definitely get a look to see three
and he will not get a rope to c 6 this
is this is clem okay we can go edge for
as long as i get the rook to see three
it does not matter very much that the
bishop is some kicked away from the g5
square
we try to get the Queen's off
but so is if I am now to defend you I'm
coming with Bishop see one as well
push-up see 1 2 a 3 that's a funny funny
position but maybe that's it's not that
he has many active possibilities try to
really batten down the hatches am yeah
this is the only way to open it up check
for f6 when this will open up the
position check so g5 or is this too too
hasty I can also just switch back and
attack the f pawn and maybe first King
to h6 and that I have a look a fade I
mean you cannot miss anything it's
really somewhat said position for wide
yeah I know the bishop is overloaded I
think you would have to move the bishop
now cannot play the rook to a square
where you could vary protects it too so
after the bishop move I will win the
pawn
yeah this started to go downhill after
c4 which killed his ruler pest bishop
yeah that's not the disconnect the
disconnects and for phase 4 Faith's way
of resigning that's let's a clock run
out wide forfeits due to disconnection
now it is connected ok kind of fits
yellow know sometimes you have this
feeling it happened it would happen yeah
well the really been crazy form I mean
he may be was somewhat concerned about
be three or I don't know but you simply
don't kill your own bishop like that
this is this kelsey bishop and you could
play it could play something like this
which is which I was expecting or maybe
this immediately okay here maybe here
maybe be 30 came but everything else
failing you could always do this and
this should should be quite okay for
white I mean I mean at least okay I'm
not sure about my whole maneuver here
with Bishop to b6 and h6 and so on it
should be somewhat reasonable for black
but nothing nothing great after that
yeah I mean it's just is just more
comfortable for me because I have much
better chances to activate my bishop
then here's yeah and I made a mistake I
should have played 94 immediately but ok
it's not a big deal I'm I'm still
keeping an edge and this was now I was
surprised that he went for this because
now i really get the rook to e3 and this
is such dominating situation always
attacking two weaknesses you cannot
challenge me on the C file ever it's
just very good for luck and the way it
went we had this end game where he was
simply getting overloaded long term
check check
Kevin and him he really loses one of the
pawns it was probably unavoidable it's
just the pressure is just too much those
rooks impart up no that's not going to
hold that okay well thanks for watching